ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY IS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MADAM CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ACOSTA
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES AS
TRIAL.
CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU. CHOI A.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
LOW FONG.
FRAZIER.
FREED MEN.
GALLAGHER.
ISTINA GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAY SEN.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
CAMELOT OR DOES.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MY MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN. OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SAUL LESS
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING. VOEPEL.
WALDRON
WEBER.
WOULD.
MR
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
PLEASE REPORT TO THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR TODAY'S
INVOCATION. WHICH WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB OSHITA. RIVER
NOTION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IN THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES
SOCIAL PSYCHOLOGIST BEGAN
DOCUMENTING A SYNDROME CALLED
COMPUTER PSYCHOSIS.
YOUNG PEOPLE WERE BECOMING MORE
COMFORTABLE INTERACTING WITH
SCREENS AND VIRTUAL REALITY OF
THE CYBER WORLD. THEN WITH
PEOPLE PHYSICALLY PRESENT.
THE TERM EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE
QUOTIENT WAS COINED TO DESCRIBE
THE ABILITY OR LACK OF ABILITY
TO EMPATHIZE AND SOCIALLY
INTERACT WITH OTHERS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT A STUDY
WAS DONE IN JAPAN. AND IT
REVEALED THAT A SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE OF HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE AGE STUDENTS.
WE'RE HAVING PERSONALITY AND
EMOTIONAL PROBLEMS
DUE TO EXCESSIVE TIME SPENT
INTERACTING WITH SUCH.
SCREEN CENTER KNOWLEDGE ME.
STUDY DESCRIBED A LIST OF
SYMPTOMS.
AS I READ THEM I FELT THE
SYMPTOMS DESCRIBED MANY WHO ARE
LIVING TODAY. IN THIS BUSY
HECTIC ANY BEEN CONFUSING TIME.
HERE ARE A FEW OF THE SYMPTOMS
FROM THAT LIST.
VERY SHORT TEMPERED. IMPATIENT.
CHAU LITTLE EMOTIONAL
EXPRESSION.
POOR COMMUNICATION AND SPEAKING
SKILLS.
NO REAL FRIENDSHIPS.
HAVE A HARD TIME TRUSTING
PEOPLE.
SELFISH AND EGOCENTRIC.
FAILED TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
AND SHOW A LITTLE RESPECT.
AND LITTLE APPRECIATION FOR
ANYTHING.
TODAY. I'D LIKE US TO REFLECT
AGAIN ON WHAT WE ALL KNOW WELL.
THERE IS NO REPLACEMENT FOR THE
WARMTH OF HUMAN CONTACT AND
INTERACTION.
IT IS BEEN THE LOVING
RELATIONSHIPS IN OUR LIVES THAT
HAVE NURTURED OR ABILITY TO CARE
AND APPRECIATE.
IT HAS BEEN THE LOVING
RELATIONSHIPS IN OUR LIVES. THAT
HAVE MADE US PEOPLE WORTHY OF
FRIENDSHIP.
AND CAPABLE OF LOVE.
NUMBER ONE. WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING FOR
TODAY'S PLEDGE WILL BE WHICH
WILL BE OFFERED. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW.
READY BEGAN.
COULD APPLY.
UNITED STATES OF.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS.
UNDER OUR.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY APRIL
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN A. M. ON
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THIRTY FIRST DISTRICT PRESIDING
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MS.
WALDRON SECONDS ABOUT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND.
IT'S DEEMED ADOPTED MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
OF MY
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
TODAY'S ABSENCES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABALLERO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX OVER QUESTION
AND.
TO REFER TO THE FOLLOWING BILL
COMMITTEE.
AB NINETEEN HUNDRED BROKE FROM
THE REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE LEVINE FROM
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE AB TWENTY
SEVENTY FIVE QUIRK SILVA FROM
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX
EDUARDO GARCIA FROM EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE AND SP FIVE
EIGHTEEN BERRYHILL FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON PLEASE REMOVE
ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FOUR BLOOM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THE CLERK WILL
KNOW.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US HERE TODAY IN THE
ASSEMBLY. PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES FOR HIS GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THE MENACE BEAKER AND.
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE A GROUP OF STUDENTS
AND PARENTS FROM THE SAINT
TERESA SCHOOL IN PALM SPRINGS.
AYE THEY ARE SITTING UP IN THE
GALLERY TO ASK THEM TO PLEASE
STAND.
OF THE STUDENTS ARE REMARKABLY
ACTIVE IN OUR COMMUNITY THEY
HELP SUPPORT THE CHURCH'S FOOD
BANK PROGRAM VISIT REST HOMES
AND THEY REGULARLY SUPPORT THE
TWENTY POUNDS ME CORD BASE WITH
CARE PACKAGES.
THE STUDENTS OF SAINT THERESA
SCHOOL ALSO HAVE A LOVE AND GIFT
FOR OUR LAST SUMMER THEY HAD
THEIR OWN EXHIBIT AT THE PALM
SPRINGS ARCHITECTURE DESIGN
CENTER MUSEUM.
PLEASE HELP ME EXTEND A WARM
WELCOME TO THESE AMAZING
STUDENTS THEIR FAMILIES FOR
JOINING US TODAY.
SOME OF THEM ARE CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I FOR
THE PROCEDURAL MOTION SB EIGHT
FORTY FIVE THE SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE IS AT
THE DESK I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MISTER CALDERON
STATUS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE UP IN THE
GALLERY OF THE FOURTH GRADERS IN
THE GETTING HOUSING AREA SCHOOL
IN MY. HOMETOWN OF PALO ALTO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN GIVING A WARM
WELCOME TO THESE FINE SCHOLARS
VISITING OUR STATE CAPITOL TODAY
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ THE ITEMS. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY NINE NINETY FIVE TWENTY
NINE THIRTY FIVE THIRTY SIXTY
SEVEN TWENTY SIX THIRTY FOUR
THIRTY FORTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY THREE
SIXTEEN.
TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX
THIRTY SIX POINT SEVEN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY SEVEN FORTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE. THIRTY
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE EIGHTEEN NINETY EIGHTEEN
NINETY ONE EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX NINETEEN NINETY SIX
TWENTY SEVENTY TWENTY NINETY
SIX.
TWENTY ONE FORTY TO TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX TWENTY THIRTY EIGHT
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SIX POINT TWO
SIXTY SEVEN TWENTY NINETY ONE.
POINT THREE TEN TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE NINETY FOUR TWENTY
SIX AT THREE TWENTY SIX POINT
TWO TWENTY SIX FIFTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SIX POINT SIX EIGHTY
NINE. POINT SEVEN NINETEEN POINT
SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
SIX. TWENTY NINE FIFTY TWO
TWENTY NINE E. THREE THIRTY
FORTY THIRTY ONE I ONE THIRTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR THIRTY TO TWELVE.
THIRTY TWO TWENTY NINE THIRTY TO
FORTY SIX TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN
WITH THE MOMENT SEVENTEEN FORTY
TWO WITH THE MEMONS TWENTY SIX
NBA WITH AMENDMENTS. TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO AT THE MOMENT
EIGHTEEN THIRTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE BILL NINE
FORTY ONE.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SIXTY ONE A.
B. FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER WHAT AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE TRIBAL
GAMING DECLARING THE URGENCY
THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THINKING THAT A SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT EIGHT
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE WHICH
RATIFIES THE GAMING CON. PACT
BETWEEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN THE ELK VALLEY RANCHERIA.
THE TRIBE CURRENTLY OPERATES
THAT ELK VALLEY CASINO WHICH
CONSISTS OF APPROXIMATE THREE
HUNDRED SLOT MACHINES TO
BLACKJACK TABLES. EIGHTY FIVE
ROSSI RESTAURANT A BINGO HALL
AND EVENTS CENTER THIS COMPACT
BETWEEN THE STATE IN THE WRITTEN
THE RANCHERIA ACCOUNTS FOR THE
TRIBES PLANTS.
TO TO OPEN A NEW FACILITY THE
ELK VALLEY RESORT AND CASINO AT
WHICH POINT THE CURRENT FACILITY
WOULD CLOSE CURRENTLY THE TRIBE
EMPLOYS APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY PEOPLE.
A HUNDRED HUNDRED TWENTY OF THEM
A PLOY A PLATE AT THE CASINO.
YUP DALY RANCHERIA HAS BEEN A
TREMENDOUS PARTNER ON THE NORTH
COAST THIS COMPACT PROTECTS THE
INTERESTS OF THE TRIBE.
AND IT'S MEMBERS IS RUNNING
COMMUNITY IN THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC WILL PROMOTE A SECURE
LONG TERM STABILITY MUTUAL
RESPECT AND MUTUAL BENEFITS
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SING THEIR REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES
ON THE URGENCY EYES SIXTEEN NO
ZERO.
ON THE MEASURE I SIXTEEN NO ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
ITEM SIXTY TWO THROUGH SIXTY SIX
OUR CONTINUED.
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN THROUGH SEVENTY
PASS AND RETAIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK BECAUSE
I'M SORRY A MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. ITEM.
SEVENTY TWO AB TWENTY ONE I'M
SORRY ITEM SEVENTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE NINETY EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY
EIGHT BY SILLY MEMBER QUIRK
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SOME MEMBER QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
A. B..
TWENTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT.
I JUST TO FIND AMOUNTS THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES MAY ASSESS
FOR VIOLATIONS OF BUILDING AND
SAFETY CODES.
FOR INFLATION AND CREATES A NEW
FINE FOR ADDITIONAL REPEAT
VIOLATIONS WITHIN A TWO YEAR
PERIOD.
THIS IT IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
AND THE LEAGUE OFFICE CALIFORNIA
CITIES THERE IS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY ONE AND KNOWS
FOURTEEN OF THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM SEVENTY TWO THROUGH SEVENTY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM SEVENTY SIX AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
A MEMBER COOPER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THE COMMENCEMENT REMEMBERS THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND CLARIFY THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE AMENDMENTS MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS
.
CLICK WILL CLOSER ALL TELLING
THE VOTES I THIRTY NINE NO
FIFTEEN. THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED.
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT BACKING
FILE.
ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN THROUGH
EIGHTY ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM EIGHTY TWO A. B. TWENTY
FIFTY SEVEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER SALAS AND
ACTUALLY THEM BY MENTAL QUALITY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIFTY SEVEN IS A SORT OF
EXTENSION OF A BILL THAT THIS
HOUSE PASSED PREVIOUSLY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES.
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIFTY SEVEN THIS IS A GREAT
MEASURE ONGC SPECIALLY MY AREA
WHERE WE ARE THE DAIRY CAPITAL
OF THE WORLD. ARM
THIS HELPS US.
USE THAT VERY WASTE INTERNET
INTO BIO GAS I'D LIKE TO THINK
THE.
MEMBER.
FROM BAKERSFIELD FOR THIS
LEGISLATION.
SEEING NO FURTHER REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
MR US ALWAYS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE
THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTES.
I FIFTY FIVE AT NO ZERO. THE
MOTION PASSES.
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR PASS AND
RETAIN.
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY TWO MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
TWO BY SELLING MEMBER WEBER AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOUR RECOGNIZED YES THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO WHICH
MAKES TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE.
SELECT TAPE ACCOUNTING OF STATE
INMATES IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN GOVERNOR BROWN
SIGNED A BEFORE TWENTY WHICH
STARTING WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS ALLOWS THE CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. TO
COUNT INMATES AS RESIDENTS AT
THEIR LAST KNOWN PLACE OF
RESIDENCE INSTEAD OF AT THE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY WHERE THEY
ARE INCARCERATED. NEW DISTRICT
LINES ARE BASED ON CENSUS
COUNSELORS IMPORTANT INMATES ARE
COUNTED AS PART OF THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES WHICH BETTER
REPRESENT THEM. UNDER AB FOR
TWENTY OF THE CDC OURS ALREADY
REQUIRED TO GIVE THIS
INFORMATION TO THE CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. THIS
BILL MAKES A PROCEDURAL CHANGES
THAT WILL HELP SEE VCR AND THE
CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION FULFILL THIS
RESPONSIBILITY. WE ARE STILL AN
ACTIVE CONVERSATION WITH CDC ARE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS BILL
MEETS THEIR NEEDS AS WE APPROACH
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS. THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS AND HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AYE MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. AYE THIS BILL SIMPLY
HELPS IMPLEMENT WHAT IS BAD LAW
OF WHAT THIS IS SIMPLY ABOUT IS
ABOUT TRYING TO GET PEOPLE I
COUNTED IN DISTRICTS NOT WHERE
THEY LIVE. UP. IN PRISON UP BUT
WHERE THEY FORMALLY WORK I TAKE
PROVIDE AN EXTREME CASE OUT YOU
HAVE A SITUATION HERE WHERE
MANSON FAMILY MEMBER PATRICIA
KRENWINKEL. SERVING A LIFE
SENTENCE FOR MURDER WOULD BE
COUNTED AS A RESIDENT OF
CHATSWORTH IN LOS ANGELES.
WHERE SHE AYE LIVED AYE BEFORE
HER NINETEEN SIXTY NINE ARRESTS
EVEN THOUGH SHE HAS RESIDED IN
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION OF
WOMEN IN CHINO SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE? PEOPLE SHOULD BE
COUNTED WHERE THEY LIVE IN THE
CENSUS AND THOUGH DISTRICT
SHOULD BE ACCORDINGLY DRAWN IN
THAT WAY. NOT IN A WAY THAT
SIMPLY TRIES TO PACK PEOPLE INTO
URBAN AREAS.
TO GIVE SPECIFIC ADVANTAGES TO
THE MAJORITY PARTY ARGENEAU
VOTE.
THANK YOU S. SOME REMEMBER WEBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
FOR AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY ONE THEM
BUT THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS EIGHTY SIX THROUGH EIGHTY
EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM EIGHTY NINE A. B. EIGHTEEN
OH TO MATTER QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN NOTES YOU
BY FAMILY MEMBER SALAS AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOLACE
YOU RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SIMPLY BILL EIGHTEEN NO TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FOUR THREE FROM LAST
YEAR. THAT TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
CLEAN UP LANGUAGE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS AND NINETY AND NINETY ONE
PASS AND RETAIN
.
ITEM NINETY TWO A BE THIRTY
THIRTY SIX MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THIRTY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
COOLEY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE AMENDMENTS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I HAVE AMENDMENTS HERE
ON AB THIRTY THIRTY SIX THIS
CONCERNS.
A DEFINITIONS PERTAIN TO SOLID
WASTE.
YOU MEMBERS OF THE VAST REPLACED
THE TERM INTENDED WITH THE TERM
DESTINED.
AS RELATES TO THE USE OF SOLID
WASTE AS ANIMAL FEED.
OF THEIR PRODUCT OF
CONVERSATIONS BILLS MOVE
FORWARD.
AND.
SPECIFIC RESPONDER A QUESTION
RAISED BY WASTE HAULERS WHO ARE
FORMALLY OPPOSED THE BILL. AND
WERE DRESSED IN OUR FACILITIES
AND MOMENTS OUR CUSTOMERS WE PUT
OUT THE PRINT BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY
BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED PLEASE SAY
NAY.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE.
ITEMS NINETY THREE THROUGH
NINETY FIVE PASSED AND RETAIN.
ITEM NINETY SIX HR NINETY NINE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY NINE BY SOME
THE MEMBER DAVID CHIU RELATIVE
TO LUPUS AWARENESS MONTH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU YOUR
RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES FUTURE NINETY NINE
DESIGNATES MAY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS LUPUS AWARENESS
MONTH.
LUPUS IS A CHRONIC AUTOIMMUNE
DISEASE THAT CAUSES INFLAMMATION
OF VARIOUS PARTS OF THE BODY
PARTICULARLY.
SKIN JOINTS KIDNEYS AND THE
HEART.
WE ALL KNOW SOMEONE WHO HAS
LUPUS AN ESTIMATED ONE AND A
HALF MILLION AMERICANS SUFFER
FROM LUPUS AND EVERY YEAR AT
LEAST A HUNDRED THOUSAND MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WILL BE
DIAGNOSED WITH THIS DISEASE. IT
IS TWO TO THREE TIMES MORE
PREVALENT AMONG PEOPLE OF COLOR
INCLUDING AFRICAN AMERICANS
LATINOS ASIANS AND NATIVE
AMERICANS.
SEVENTY THREE PERCENT OF
AMERICANS BETWEEN THE AGES OF
EIGHTEEN AND THIRTY FOUR HAVE
EITHER NEVER HEARD OF LUPUS OR
KNOW LITTLE OR NOTHING ABOUT THE
DISEASE BEYOND ITS NAME. THIS IS
PARTICULAR DISTURBING BECAUSE
THIS IS THE EXACT AGE GROUP AT
GREATEST RISK FOR THE DISEASE.
TODAY WE DECLARE THE MONTH THE
MAY AS LUPUS AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA TO RAISE AWARENESS OF
THIS DISEASE AND RECOGNIZE THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS DO THE CRUCIAL
WORK TO BEAT THE DISEASE. I LIKE
TO ASK THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
YOUR RECORD I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MATTER SPEAKER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M ACTUALLY VERY PLEASED.
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
ARE.
I'VE ACTUALLY KNOWN TO RULES
CHAIRS.
WHOSE WIVES WERE AFFECTED BY
LUPUS.
AND.
MY FIRST BOSS LIEU PAP WAS
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS LEAD FOOT
LOU.
LEAD FOOT LOU BECAUSE HE WOULD
DRIVE RAPIDLY BETWEEN SACRAMENTO
AND
IS HOME AND BILBRAY.
A HE WAS TO CONVERT HE WAS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM THE AREA OF
LEO RYAN WHO WAS GUNNED DOWN IN
GUYANA.
YOU MAY SOME OF YOU REMEMBER
THIS STORY JACKIE SPEAR WAS
INJURED THAT DAY.
HE WAS ASKED TO RUN FOR THE
COMING CONGRESS.
WOULD HAVE BEEN A SHOE NGUYEN.
AND THE HIS WIFI RAIN HAD SEVERE
LUPUS.
AND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PABON OPTED NOT
TO RUN FOR THE CONGRESS BECAUSE
OF THE MEDICAL CARE.
SHE GOT AT UCSF.
IT WAS A VERY DEVASTATED DISEASE
THAT HE READ RECKLESS POLITICAL
CAREER. IN ORDER TO SUPPORT HIS
WIFE AS SHE DEALT WITH THIS
WHICH YOU AND SHE PASSED AWAY
FROM.
SO THIS IS A.
TREMENDOUS RESOLUTION IT IS A
VERY DEBILITATING CONDITION.
IT GREATLY AFFECTS THE
INDIVIDUALS THEIR FAMILIES THEIR
FRIENDS
AND I'M.
SO GREAT ABOUT FOR THE DAY
MISTER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA YOU
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AYE I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THE. HR NINETY NINE IN MEMORY.
OF MY HOBBY LE.
DIETER OF MY COLLEAGUES AT POLY
HIGH SCHOOL RUBEN.
AND.
LUPE AGUILERA.
WHO DIED WHEN A STUDENT?
AT POLY HIGH SCHOOL IN
RIVERSIDE OF LUPUS.
RUBIN AND LUPE WE'RE HERE ON THE
FLOOR LAST YEAR WHEN WE
COMMEMORATED. AND.
PASSED
A MAY AS LUPUS AWARENESS MONTH
AND AYE AYE AS A SUPPORT OF HR
NINETY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER TO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I WANT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM RANCHO CORDOVA AND
RIVERSIDE FOR SHARING THEIR
PERSONAL CONNECTION WITH THIS
DISEASE. IN MY TWENTIES I HAD
SOME OF THOSE CLOSE WITH TO ME
WHO ALSO LUPUS.
WE ARE ALL IMPACTED EVERYONE OF
US KNOWS AT LEAST ONE IF NOT
MORE INDIVIDUALS WHO EXPERIENCE
AND SUFFER FROM THIS DISEASE AND
WITH THIS I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MADAM SPEAKER
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE THIS ROLE
IS FOR CO AUTHOR. AUTHORS ON THE
RESIN.
THIS RULE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CALL AUTHORS.
RENDON QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
ALTHOUGH WE WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE WITHOUT OBJECTION ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE
OF THE ITEM PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
EYES AS ITEMS THAT NINETY SEVEN
THROUGH NINETY NINE PASS AND
RETAIN.
I DON'T ONE HUNDRED AG ARE
TWENTY EIGHT MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OF ONE MOMENT.
I BEG YOUR PARDON WE'RE GONNA
RETURN TO MR CHIU FOR HIS GAS
INTRODUCTIONS
THANK YOU MENACE BAKER HOW
COLLEAGUES IN THE GALLERY TODAY
WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
LUPUS FOUNDATION.
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IF YOU
COULD PLEASE JOIN ME.
IN ISSUING A WARM WELCOME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
THINK YOU. RETURNING NOW TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
MADAM CLERK AG ARE.
TWENTY EIGHT ITEM ONE HUNDRED
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AJ ARE TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH CALLS FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. TO TAKE ACTIONS THAT
WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA PROVIDE
BANKING SERVICES TOITS LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ON NOVEMBER
SIXTEENTH ON NOVEMBER TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
VOTED TO LEGALIZE. THE
RECREATIONAL USE OF CANNABIS IN
OUR STATE DESPITE THIRTY EIGHT
STATES HAVING LEGALIZE CANNABIS
FOR MEDICAL OR ADULT USE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CONTINUES TO
AFFIRM HIS AUTHORITY TO CLASSIFY
CANNABIS AS A SCHEDULE ONE DRUG.
AS SUCH FEDERAL POLICY
DISCOURAGES FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS FROM PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THE CANVAS INDUSTRY
AND MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
STATES TO SET UP THEIR OWN.
BANKING SYSTEM TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY WHICH IS EXPECTED TO BE
WORTH SIX POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS BY TWENTY TWENTY IS NO
DIFFERENT. AND LEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESSES STRUGGLE TO FIND
BANKING SERVICES AND IS FORCED
TO MAKE ALL TRANSACTIONS IN CASH
MAKING THESE BUSINESSES
VULNERABLE TO CRIME AND PUTS THE
SAFETY OF OWNERS. CUSTOMERS AND
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOODS AT RISK AS
CHAIR OF SIMPLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE I AM SCREAMING
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THE
PREVALENCE OF CASH ONLY
BUSINESSES WOULD DO TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. PLEASE JOIN ME
TODAY IN URGING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PRIVATIZE THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES ALLOW
STATES TO PROVIDE BANKING TO
SERVICES TO CANNABIS BUSINESSES
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK.
MISTER JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION YES.
WITHOUT ADEQUATE PLEASE OPEN THE
RULES. MEMBERS THIS ROSE FOR
COAL AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR COAUTHORS.
THIS ROLE IS OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES THERE
ARE FIFTY FOUR I.
VOTES NO THREE THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
ITEMS ONE OH ONE THROUGH ONE OF
THREE PASS AND RETAIN.
I DON'T WANT NO FOR A BI TWENTY
SIX FORTY TWO MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FORTY
TWO BY SLIMMER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY THE GUARDIANSHIP.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY TWO WILL ALLOW
MORE NON PROFITS TO SERVE AS
LEGAL GUARDIANS FOR IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN AS WE'VE HEARD THIS
WEEK IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS HAVE
BLOCKED THE ARRIVAL. FOR
HUNDREDS OF IMMIGRANTS FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA MANY ARE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS WHO ARE
FLEEING HORRIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES
THIS BILL WILL HELP THEM I'D BE
IN A PLACE THAT CAN CARE FOR
THEM. RATHER THAN IN A DETENTION
CENTER AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW HE DEVOTES.
I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE IS ADOPTED.
ITEM ONE OH FIVE PASS AND
RETAIN.
ITEM ONE OH SIX A. B. THIRTY
FORTY ONE MEDICAL PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY FORTY ONE
BY SOME THE MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
AND ACTUALLY DO REAL ESTATE
TRANSFER FEES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
PRIVATE TRANSFER FEES ARE
GENERALLY OPPOSED BY DEVELOPER
AND THEY REQUIRED THE HOME
BUYER.
AND ALL SUBSEQUENT PURCHASERS OF
A HOME
TO PAY A FEE BASED ON. THE PRICE
OF THE HOME AS A PERCENTAGE.
PROBLEM IS THAT A LOT OF PRIVATE
TRANSFER FEES.
THE DO NOT PROVIDE A DIRECT
BENEFIT AS THAT TERM IS DEFINED
IN FEDERAL LAW. ACTUALLY
DISQUALIFY BUYERS FROM OBTAINING
FINANCING THAT'S BACKED BY
FANNIE MAE AND FREDDIE MAC.
AB THIRTY FORTY ONE WILL
PROHIBIT. PRIVATE TRANSFER FEES
THAT DO NOT PROVIDE A DIRECT
BENEFIT AS THAT TERM IS DEFINED
IN FEDERAL LAW. IT WILL LINE
CALIFORNIA WITH FORTY THREE
OTHER STATES.
IT WILL PREVENT.
HOME BUYERS FROM THE UNWELCOME
SURPRISE WHEN THEY CAN'T GET.
FINANCING TO BUY A HOME AND
SELLERS FROM USING A SALE.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT ENOUGH THAT
THIS FEE WILL NOT. THERE THIS
BILL WILL NOT ANYWAY IMPACT THE
ABILITY TO PUT ON.
.
THINGS INTO A DEVELOPMENT THAT
MIGHT BE GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT PARK CONSERVATION SO
FORTH.
IT PASSED
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
BOOK THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TELLY THE BOATS AYE
SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS HEROES THE
MEASURE PASSES
I DON'T WANT NO SEVEN AJ ARE
THIRTY SIX MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
THIRTY SIX BY SOME A MEMBER TING
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR FULL
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING MISTER TING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED HIM OUT OF SPEAKER
IT.
AJ ARE THIRTY SIX RECOGNIZES MAY
SIXTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AS THE
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
ANNIVERSARY OF THE SIGNING OF
THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT.
I WAS YOU KNOW THE FIRST TIME IN
THE ONLY TIME IN AMERICAN
HISTORY WILL BE ACTUALLY
EXCLUDED A RACE OF INDIVIDUALS
FROM. IMMIGRATING AND MOVING
INTO THE UNITED STATES OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S A VERY DARK STAIN ON
HISTORY BUT THE REASON WE BRING
IT UP AGAIN. IS WE ARE FAIR
FEARING THAT THERE WE ARE IN A
VERY SIMILAR XENOPHOBIC CLIMATE
RIGHT NOW. WITH THE MUSLIM BAND
WITH PEOPLE BEING BANNED BECAUSE
OF WHERE THEY'RE COMING FROM
COUNTRIES WHERE THEY'RE COMING
FROM OUR RELIGIOUS ORIENTATION.
AGAIN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE RECOGNIZE WHERE WE'VE BEEN IN
ORDER TO KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING.
AND BY DOING THAT WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE HISTORY RECOGNIZE
WHERE WE HAVE MADE MISTAKES BUT
ALSO NOT WANTING TO REPEAT THOSE
MISTAKES SO WITH THAT I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AJ ARE. THIRTY
SIX.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IS THE SON OF CHINESE
IMMIGRANTS AND AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE OLDEST
CHINATOWN IN OUR COUNTRY. I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
DECADES AGO RATHER THAN
RECOGNIZING CHINESE AMERICANS
FOR THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS AND
HELPING TO BUILD THE START IN
THE HISTORY OF OUR STATE. THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY THAT WE STAND
ON TOOK ACTION TO INTENTIONALLY
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST THOSE
CALIFORNIANS OF CHINESE DESCENT.
AFTER THE PASSAGE OF THE
EXCLUSION ACTS OUR STATE
AUTHORIZES SEGREGATION OF
CHINESE AMERICANS IN SCHOOLS AND
HOSPITALS AND OTHER PUBLIC
FACILITIES. AS WELL AS ALLOW FOR
ALIEN LAND LAWS IN ANTI
MISCEGENATION LAWS TO PREVENT
CHINESE AMERICANS FROM OWNING
PROPERTY. THIS WAS CALIFORNIA
LAW UNTIL THE NINETEEN FIFTIES
AS THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL MIGHT
WESTSIDE COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO MENTION IF WE DO NOT
REMEMBER HISTORY WE WILL REPEAT
IT.
LAST WEEK THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAME TO OUR STATE CAPITOL. AND
WE HEARD FROM ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
YOUNG GIRLS WHO HAD HIT JOBS
RIPPED FROM THEIR HEADS BOYS WHO
ARE BULLIED IN THE CLASSROOM.
HISTORY IS REPEATING ITSELF
TODAY WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
STAND UP FOR THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN
CHU YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
SEC HUMAN DOWN SPEAKER OUTSIDE
OF A RECENT CHINESE AMERICAN A
IMMIGRANT FROM TAIWAN I RISE TO
SUPPORT. AYE AGE YOUR*
THIRTY SIX AND I'M HONORED TO BE
A CO AUTHOR. THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION RIGHT AT A ACT WAS
BASED ON PREJUDICE AND FEAR AND
HATE AND THAT WAS A HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX YEARS AGO. SINGS THEM
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT VALUE OF TO
IMMIGRANTS AND THE REFUGEES AND
THE HAVE THE WITNESSES STICK
CONTRIBUTION OF THOSE COMING
INTO THE COUNTRY SINKING FOR
BETTER LIFE. AGE YOUR*
THIRTY SIX IS TO KEEP MOVING
FORWARD AND NOT BACKWARDS I'D
URGE FOR YOUR AYE BOTH.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON A
THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAM
CISCO FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT.
BOB OF MEASURE FORWARD.
IN IN SAN JOSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS REPRESENTING. A
WIDE RANGE OF ETHNICITIES GIVE A
LITTLE PORTUGAL JAPAN TOWN A
LITTLE SAIGON. WE DON'T HAVE A
CHINA TOWN THAT'S BECAUSE THE
CHINATOWNS WE HAD WERE ALL
BURNED DOWN.
SEVERAL TIMES.
BETWEEN EIGHTEEN SIXTY AND THE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTIES. AROUND THE
TIME OF THIS EXCLUSION ACT BEING
PUT INTO FORCE OF LAW AND SO.
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
NOT ONLY THAT WE REMEMBER
HISTORY BUT AS INDICATED BY MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WE DO NOT ALLOW
HISTORY TO REPEAT ITSELF THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDING YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT.
OF AJ OUR THIRTY SIX ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS.
THIS MEASURE RECOGNIZES MAY SIX
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS A
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX ANNIVERSARY
OF THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT.
THIS RACISM DISCRIMINATORY
POLICY DENIED CHINESE PEOPLE A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP. FOR MORE
THAN SIXTY YEARS.
IMMIGRATION HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR NATION'S
HISTORY.
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
HAVE COME TO AMERICA AND BROUGHT
WITH THEM NEW IDEAS.
AN IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
OUR SOCIETY AS A WHOLE.
DIVERSITY INCLUSION ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE WHAT SETS OUR NATION
APART.
WOULD MAKE AND WHAT MAKES OUR
NATION GREAT.
THERE ARE THOSE.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SEE US REVERT
TO HARMFUL POLICIES LIKE THIS
ONCE AGAIN DENYING CITIZENSHIP
AND REFUGE THE PEOPLE THEY
PERCEIVED AS DANGEROUS?
WE MUST NEVER FORGET HOW
DANGEROUS THESE POLICIES CAN BE
OR HOW MUCH HARM THEY CAN CAUSE
OUR COMMUNITIES.
AJ ARE THIRTY SIX REMINDS US TO
HONOR THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
IMMIGRANTS IN THIS COUNTRY AND
TO CONDEMN ANY POLICIES. THAT
SEEK TO THREATEN WHAT WE AS
AMERICANS AND CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA STAND FOR.
I URGE SUPPOSED BOARD FOR AJ ARE
THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS I RISE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF HR THIRTY SIX. WHICH
COMMEMORATES THE CRITICAL
LESSONS OF THE CHINESE EXCLUSION
ACT AND THE HARDSHIPS ENDORSED
BY THE PEOPLE OF CHINESE DESCENT
IN THE UNITED STATES WHILE
CONDEMNING THE ACTS DISTURBING
PARALLELS TO APPAREL FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS IMMIGRATION
POLICIES OF TODAY.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE
DIVERSE FIFTY FIRST DISTRICT I
AM PROUD TO REPRESENT CHINATOWN
IN LOS ANGELES. I HAVE HEARD THE
STORIES OF THE CHINESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WHO GATHERED IN THESE
COMMUNITIES TO FIND SANCTUARY.
FROM THE RESENTMENT AND STRIFE
THAT CAME ABOUT THE TIME OF THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT.
DECADES LATER SOME FAMILIES
STILL REMEMBER. IN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TWO DESPITE PEOPLE OF
CHINESE DESCENT COMING TO THE U.
S. AND MAKING CONTRIBUTIONS.
LIKE BUILDING THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD AS
WELL AS LABORING IN BUILDING
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND THE WEST COAST. IMMIGRANTS
FROM CHINA HAD THE GATES OF TH
UNITED STATES SLAMMED SHUT IN
THEIR FACES.
THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT WAS
PASSED IN AN ERA OF FEAR.
WHERE PEOPLE OF CHINESE DESCENT
WERE LABELED AS YELLOW*
WHEDON'S?
DIRTY.
EVEN SAYING THOSE WORDS
GIVES ME.
TREMENDOUS.
FEELINGS ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE FACING TODAY.
ADDED TO THAT THERE WAS
WIDESPREAD PARANOIA THE LED MANY
IN THE U. S. TO BELIEVE THAT THE
CHINESE PEOPLE WERE HERE TO TAKE
OUR JOBS AND UNDERCUT OUR WAGES.
SOUNDS LIKE VERY SIMILAR
PARALLEL LANGUAGE OF TODAY.
THERE ARE MANY DISGRACEFUL
PARALLELS TO THE SENTIMENT THAT
EXISTS WHICH ARE DIRECTED TO
IMMIGRANTS OF ALL BACKGROUNDS
MOST OF WHICH THAT HATEFUL
SENTIMENT IS DIRECTED TOWARDS
THE LATINO IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
OF TODAY.
THE CHINESE EXCLUSION NOT SET UP
A PATTERN OF SEEN A PHOBIA
IMMIGRATION POLICIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME IN OUR
HISTORY WERE AN ENTIRE GROUP WAS
EXCLUDED FROM COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES SOLELY ON THE
BASIS OF THEIR ETHNICITY.
TRAGICALLY THIS BIGOTRY IS STILL
GOING ON TODAY.
WE DON'T NEED TO LOOK ANY
FURTHER THAN TODAY'S HEADLINES
REGARDING THE RESCINDING OF TPS
THE MISGUIDED CALLS FOR A
FOOLISH BORDER WALL IN THE
PROPOSED MUSLIM BAND.
TO.
SIVA DAMAGE
THAT THIS DISCRIMINATION HAS
DONE AND CONTINUES TO DO SO BY
DIVIDING PEOPLE FROM VARIOUS
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS ACROSS OUR
STATE AND ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
I SUGGEST WE TAKE A HARD LOOK
INTO OUR PAST.
AND INTO OUR HEARTS THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER.
TO BREAK THIS DESTRUCTIVE
PATTERN OF HATRED AND BIGOTRY.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO COMMEND OUR
CHINESE AMERICAN COMMUNITY FOR
ALL THEIR COMMITMENTS.
THAT HAVE PERSISTED.
IN THE FACE OF THIS INCREDIBLE
INJUSTICE.
I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR AUTHORING THIS
RESOLUTION AND FOR HIGHLIGHTING
THIS THESE ISSUES AND I STRONGLY
URGE AND AYE VOTES ON ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION NOR DEBATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIANG WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THE AYE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I THINK THIS RESOLUTIONS
REMINDER. TO ALL OF US THAT KNOW
WHO HAVE IMMIGRANT BACKGROUNDS
WHICH I BELIEVE IS EVERYONE IN
THE ROOM WHETHER YOU'RE FAMILIES
CAME FROM ITALY OR GERMANY. OR
IRELAND OR CHINA OR.
ANY PART OF THE WORLD OR FROM
MEXICO IT IS IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT PATH THAT.
AT TIMES WAS VERY CHALLENGING.
BUT ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE
AT THE BETTER FOR IT IN THE
STRONG BEFORE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE FIRST WILL
BE A PERFECT ROLE AUTHORS AND
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE ON AJ. OUR
THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE FIRST RULE OF LAW.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR COAL
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THE AUTHORS REQUESTING CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MATTER QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FORTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
ON THE ITEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FOURTEEN.
EYES FORTY NINE AT NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
RELATIVE TO INTERGENERATIONAL
TRAUMA.
ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES THERE ARE
SIXTY SIXTY NINE I KNOW ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED THE
REMAINDER OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS WILL BE READ BY
THE LAST MEMBER WITH A VOTE
CHANGE.
WE ARE RETURNING NOW TO GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
FULL ATTENTION MEMBERS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER FOR A VERY
SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER FOR THE
CALL FOR FULL ATTENTION WE'VE
GOT A GREAT INTRODUCTION I'D
LIKE TO MAKE FOR YOU THE FOURTH
GRADE CLASS OF JAMES VU FROM
FAIR LANDS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
PLEASANTON. THEY JUST WROTE IN
FROM THE DISTRICT JUST IN TIME
TO SEE ALL OF US
FAIRLY ENDS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IS
A DISTINGUISHED SCHOOL FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND HAS BEEN A
DISTINGUISHED SCHOOL FOUR YEARS
PRIOR. THANK YOU TO THE GREAT
TEACHERS THE KIDS THE CHAPERONES
WELCOME PLEASE THE FAIRLAND
SQUIRES.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
MAY FOURTH NO FLOOR SESSION NO
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY MAY
SEVENTH FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN A MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SITTING IN
HERE THERE NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
MR.
MS BAKER MOVES AND MISTER DALLI
SECONDS AT THE HOUSE DOWN
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY MAY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
A. B. TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN.
I TO NOT VOTING.
IT'S A NIGHTMARE MEDINA.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTY
SEVEN.
AYE AYE IT'S NOT VOTING
.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE CONSENT
ITEMS.
S. UNABLE TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT WISHING TO FOURTEEN I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO NINE BILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO LABEL
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO CYCLE TWENTY EIGHTEEN. I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO LABEL TWENTY
EIGHTY SIX I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
SINGLE TWENTY ANY FIVE I SIXTY
NINE KNOWS ZERO LIMITS ANYONE
KNOW NINE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO.
ONE NINETY TWO I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO SYMBOL TYPE REAL ONE I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SINGLE TIME
THREE FIFTY SEVEN AYE SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO SYMBOL TYPE THREE NINETY
ONE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SYMBOL
TWENTY FOUR FORTY NINE I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO ASSEMBLE TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY. EIGHT I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO PERSONAL TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO SINGLE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO LEVEL
PLAYING BY THIRTY ONE I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SINGLE TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY NINE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
SUBTLETY FIVE FORTY ONE. I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SINGLE TYPE AYE
NEEDS YOU I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
SINGLE TWENTY SIX TWENTY I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SINGLES Y. SIX
SIXTY ONE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
SOME MULTI SIX SEVENTY NINE I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SINGLE TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT. I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SINGLE TIME NINE
THIRTY EIGHT BY SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO SUBTLETY NINE FORTY FOUR I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SINGLE PLANE
I'M FORTY NINE I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO SINGLE THIRTY FOURTEEN. I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SYMBOL THIRTY
FORTY SEVEN AYE SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO SUM UP THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SINGLE
THIRTY SEVENTY EIGHT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SINGLE THIRTY ONES
WHILE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
SYMBOL THIRTY ONE POINT TWO. I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SYMBOL THIRTY
ONE THIRTY THREE I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO I'M A THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
SINGLE THANK YOU THIRTY ONE I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE.
RESOLUTION ONE OF THREE BY SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE RESOLUTION
ONE NINETEEN I SIXTY NINE DOZER
AND SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE THIRTY I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO